The algorithm is correct, or the search tree is correct,
because it still tries all possibilities;
it's just smarter about avoiding stupid possibilities.
And what I mean by this is basically that it deliberately avoids this case here
where you have 2 endpoints of an edge not being in the vertex cover,
so it tries to avoid those.
Are there special cases where the algorithm could be wrong? No.
It still searches through all possibilities.
Again, it just does so in an intelligent way to avoid making any stupid choices.
Does the search tree at each level determine the assignment of at least 1 vertex? Yes.
That one is definitely true because if all edges would be covered,
then the algorithm would be done; the search tree would not go much further.
The usual case would be that we actually do an assignment for 2 vertices,
and this will also tell you something about the answer down here.
So usually when we have an edge that is not covered,
we will have the case that we actually determine the assignment for 2 vertices.
There is 1 special case, and if you have found that special case yourself,
then you have truly understood search trees.
But if you haven't, then just listen closely and don't worry too much about it.
There might be the following case, where you have an edge that is not yet covered
but you've already made the decision for 1 of the endpoints.
The question is now what to do with this one here.
But this is actually a case that is rather easy
because here we don't really have to make a choice anymore
because we know this edge must be covered.
So whenever we decide for 1 vertex that it is not going to be part of the vertex cover,
then we can put all of its neighbors into the vertex cover automatically.
We do not need to make a choice here anymore,
and this is why we can construct the search tree so that at each level
we determine the assignment of at least 2 vertices.
Just to make this very clear, let me show you this again here in this example.
Let's go back 1 level.
When we made the choice here to not put this vertex into the vertex cover,
we could immediately also have said that this vertex here must be part of the vertex cover
because otherwise this edge here cannot be covered and we would already have been done.
And the same thing up here.
So if we decide that this vertex is not part of the vertex cover,
then we immediately know that this vertex must come into the vertex cover
because otherwise this edge here would not be covered,
and we also know because of this edge here that we have to put this vertex here
into the vertex cover, so we are also done, having found a slightly larger solution.
The only thing where we still need to make a decision is this part down here.
There we can still go into 3 cases, either putting that one into the vertex cover, that one, or both.
And this is of course something that an algorithm can do as well.
So actually, we get down to 5 assignments here,
which already makes this search tree better than the one we started out with.
But now comes the really cool part
because once we know that we can construct the search tree
so that at each level we determine the assignment of at least 2 vertices,
we can do a pretty, pretty cool worst case analysis of that search tree.
So let me show you.